like Floria from pro football talk kind
enough to drive bring in Mike Florio
from Pro Football Talk Mike did the NFL
have it out for the Oakland Raiders for
Oakland I mean you wanted to keep the
team for one more year that's fine you
got nine weeks between games but not an
easy start to the season for what will
be the last season in Oakland and a lot
of expectations with you rival Antonia
Brown and even more pressure on Derek
Carr Dan I think that if this thing
doesn't succeed for the Raiders of this
year it's not going to be drawn Gruden's
fault it's not going to be at Sony or
Browns fault it's gonna be Derek Forrest
fault if you're looking at the schedules
it's always there's always quirky things
you talked about how the Raider is going
a long period of not playing at home I
think Tampa Bay has that as well but if
I said the easiest schedule does it
always go back to the Patriots because
they play in the AFC East well yeah but
we keep waiting for the other three
teams to step up and one of these years
I guess they will but you know look at
the Dolphins right out of it gates with
a new coach a team that has not been
good they've got four straight playoff
opponents from 2018 that they have to
try to navigate and it really is
critical to try you know with a new
coach to get off to a good start win
some games develop some confidence and
that's the thing no matter what the rest
of the schedule is for the Patriots
there's still six games being played
against these teams in the AFC East the
tries they might just can't compete with
the Patriots and when you look at the
Patriots schedule this year most of
their tough games are at home and we
know that they are a much better team at
home than they are on the road also when
the NFL puts out this schedule how much
thought goes into how bad a team was to
help them because we see this in in in
football more than any other sport where
it feels like the schedule is there to
help out the you know the bottom feeders
and maybe penalize those who won their
division the previous year is that a
myth or is that fact well it's a fact
that it's not as significant as it used
to be once they switch to this current
format Dan with eight divisions four
teams each there's only two games per
year that fluctuate based upon where you
finished in your
that's it two games the other 14 games
are set in advance you can go out years
as long as the NFL sticks with the
current formula and you can figure out
14 of 16 opponents for every team it's
those last two games that are tied to
where you finish in your division if
your workplace team you play two other
fourth place teams if you're a first
place team you play two other first
place teams and I think it makes it
harder for a team that won a Division I
don't know that it necessarily makes it
easier for a team that came in fourth
but that's it it's just two games now
we've seen how teams get bunched
together one or two games can make all
the difference but it used to be a
bigger advantage when there were fewer
teams in a different configuration but
but now those two games are all that you
get if you finish in fourth place in a
given division why don't they wait until
after the draft to do release the
schedule I know there's at least one
owner that would very much like to do
that the question is can they ever cause
that to coalesce it makes sense because
why do you need to know the schedule
before the drafts like hey I faced
Patrick Holmes week one instead of week
12 okay I'm going to draft a different
guy in round 3 because of it I don't
think that's realistic and from the
perspective of locking in where calibre
is going to be I mean Arizona becomes a
more attractive team for early season
scheduling if we know calibre is going
to be their quarterback so you wait till
after the draft you see what trades may
happen during the draft that could
change the landscape of the the coming
season and and you know with the NFL
understanding the value of primetime
games that can generate big ratings can
help support the big dollars they're
here to come on the next TV contract I
think it just makes sense to have as
much information as possible before you
put the schedule out there and it's just
a matter of waiting a week or two after
the draft and you know maybe you have a
schedule ready to go and you just make
some tweaks based upon what happens in
the draft but I don't see any reason to
not do it and maybe it's a conversation
the NFL eventually will have he's Mike
Florio from pro football talk.com
Pro Football Talk live on the NBC Sports
Network when I say worst team in the NFL
which team comes to mind well yeah you
know it's so hard this time of year and
no fans want to hear that their team is
the worst because it's zero and zero
there's always hope that it's going to
turn around but I think the Dolphins
right now because I kind of think it's
some level they want to be I think at
the ownership level
there's a recognition that sometimes you
just got to take a step back take your
lumps and hope you can position yourself
to get that franchise quarterback on a
rookie contract it's going to help turn
your team around it's been 20 years
since Dan Marino retired
they've been fumbling around for a
quarterback ever since they could have
had to rebreathe they they were freaked
out by his shoulder so they took Dante
Culpepper with a wreck knee and gave up
a second-round pick to get him instead I
mean this may be their opportunity and
if they start off on four after facing
four playoff teams then maybe they can
sink to the bottom and begin the process
of rising to the top so right now I
would say that but but who knows because
every year there's a team that we think
is going to be bad and they surprise us
and that's that's the beauty of taking
it one week at its on one game at a time
because you know if a new coach can
start off with a couple of unexpected
wins guys buy in and the next thing you
know it's like the Bears last year you
have a team that's in playoff contention
you look at these contracts here Russel
Wilson with his new contract who's going
to benefit the most from that contract
that Russ signed probably Patrick
mahomes I mean there's talk about that
Prescott but I think this cycle of the
next quarterback up becoming the
highest-paid player in league history is
over for now we went through two years
of it where Derek Carr gets leapfrog by
Matthew Stafford and then Jimmy
Garoppolo and then Kirk Cousins and Matt
Ryan and Aaron Rodgers now Russell
Wilson
I think Prescott probably should fall in
that 25 to 30 million-dollar range I
think it's going to be my homes that
ultimately goes one-up on Russell Wilson
and then the question becomes one of the
Browns do about Baker Mayfield and
there's constantly this churn Dan well
you know there's a young quarterback
franchise quarterback has success what
do you do to keep him around what's the
alternative there's a thought that at
some point one of these teams is going
to say to a quarterback who's up for a
big contract we're not going to do it
you know I think maybe the Rams and
Jared Goff would be the first team and
quarterback to have that kind of a
thought where Sean McKay would be
confident he could find somebody else
who could do just as well in that system
but but at some point someone is going
to say we're just not paying huge money
we're not going to put that much of our
salary cap into one guy we'd rather roll
the dice with a rookie and coach him up
it came a lot less money and have talent
around
if the Cardinals are sold on Cuyler
Murray the the waiting game here is it's
that they're waiting for the best and
final offer for Josh Rose I'm trying to
understand this logic here of I get the
feeling that Arizona is not getting the
trade offers for Josh Rosen that they
thought that they were going to and
maybe that's why they're kind of holding
off holding out hope your thoughts on
that process well you know I'm in I'm in
a very small minority that the Cardinals
just keep Josh Rosen they've already
paid him 11 million dollars for last
year his contract carries 6.2 million
over the next three years why not keep
them around why not wait and see if you
don't have a trade offer that you're
like for now don't do it I also think
that there's a showbusiness element to
all of this I think the NFL and the
Cardinals at some point had a
conversation about the value of keeping
all cards close to the vest until it's
time to to put caller Murray's name on
on the draft card and submit it because
then it's maximum interest on ABC ESPN
and NFL Network and I really do think
that that is a very big part of this
because look they they want this TV show
to be as compelling as possible and it's
not as compelling if Josh Rosen gets
traded before next Thursday it's not as
compelling if they would sign Paula
Murray to a contract before next
Thursday but I think everything is
pointing to Tyler Murray
they did their hype video of their
scheduled release on the Cardinals
website and learn if it's you know David
Johnson Patrick Peterson Chandler Jones
are all in it there's no sign of any
quarterback if they're keeping Josh Rose
and they're hanging this guy out to dry
before they finalized that decision I
think it's going to be Murray and then
the question becomes do they trade rosin
during the draft after the draft they
keep for a year what do they do but you
know in this league I don't think it's a
bad thing to have a couple of
quarterbacks you feel good about as long
as you you can keep the peace internally
between rose and Murray and the rest of
the teammates well that's why I thought
the Eagles should have kept Nick Foles
because I if you weren't completely sure
signing off on Carson Wentz you know
Carson Wentz his contracts not killing
you Nick Foles would it cost you but at
least you have the back-up plan in place
so I I thought that maybe they'd hold on
to him for one more year the deep pay 25
million to you back up
starters making a fraction of that well
I do it for the the Eagles are built to
win now and if you think that you can
still win now I gotta have the insurance
that I can put a quarterback in there
who's gonna be able to help us I don't
want to put Lintz out there because we
got rid of Nick Foles and hey you know
now you got to go out there and suck it
up and play or now what is Plan B of
course in whens can't go or he's not
going to be 100% this year so I was just
looking at what's at stake this year
with that team with that talent in that
division
hey I agree with you I tell you what
I'll take it one step farther I thought
they just should have should have kept
full sign and do a long-term deal and
traded Carson Wentz I mean if you can't
stay healthy you can't be a franchise
quarterback and I'm not convinced once
can stay healthy and I think look and
maybe this falls in the hot J category
but I think when sits the better
quarterback but I think the Eagles are
the better team
when Falls is on the field I mean they
have the Jobu style shrine that falls in
the locker room so they had they had to
get rid of false or when's it wasn't
going to work with both and and I would
have had a problem with them moving on
from limps and keeping Nick Foles yeah
but the problem with trading winches
what do you get for wins because he's
damaged goods
well back to what we said earlier with
the dolphin they gave up a second round
pick for Dante Culpepper on one leg you
know teams there's always going to be a
team out there that is desperate for a
franchise quarterback and I think now
the pendulum is swinging toward teams
rolling the dice on a rookie but still
if once was on the market I'd be curious
to know nothing was reported along these
lines I think the Eagles would have been
very careful about it but I'd be curious
to know what one of these teams that
really needed quarterback would have
given up to get a Carson Wentz away from
the Philadelphia Eagles my great stuff
as always we appreciate your time thank
you
all right that's Mike Florio pro
football talk comm Pro Football Talk
live in the NBC Sports Network for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app